Hello Freak bitches like way over the line.
Yeah,
because then you can't do critical government stuff.
It's still legal precedent that's set.
That then makes the craziest shit possible where it's like,
oh,
this is a words are violence.
These words are violence.
I'm raped now.
No one can say like,
our new president is horrible.
You know,
like now you can't even show descent.
It's all just a way to tighten the screws.
Don't you think that people in the left or showing dissent more than like a
violent descent towards the president,
like really like,
angry,
like in a way that I can't remember anybody doing towards Obama now to the point
where it freaks me out.
Like they're like,
it's weird.
Well,
I didn't,
I wasn't obviously traveling in the right circles.
Look for people that really angry at Obama,
but even the people that I saw online that are angry and um,
they were calling them in competent or fool or spend it all of our money and all
this different accusations,
but not like what I'm seeing with trump.
Like I'm seeing just like flat out insults from famous people all the time.
Yeah,
and the media,
I don't get white people totally trust immediate.
It's like you'll see them misrepresent something in such an egregious way and my
dad is a rhetoric professor so it's like he teaches a class in propaganda.
This is like my whole childhood is learned about the shit.
I'm watching CNN.
I'm like,
you motherfuckers,
you know exactly like you can misrepresent things.
So agregious Lee,
that I'm like,
of course no one's going to trust you and that's a problem.
Right?
And it's not that you.
You don't wish that they were correct,
right?
It's that in them lying.
Even if you're on their side more than you're on the Fox News,
CNN lies even a little.
Then it's fuel for the other side and it vastly diminishes the impact that you
can have because you're not.
You're not trustworthy anymore.
So literally that's all you have in news now is trustworthiness because everyone
can manipulate and photoshop.
Now that,
that,
that Audio Photoshop,
oh my God.
It's like you have to just trust people.
I can't trust anybody though.
It's real issue and an issue with an issue with the left being so hyperbolic.
It's like when trump was first elected,
I was like,
ah,
sucks,
trump's crazy.
And then I saw their reaction and almost like triaged it when I was like,
wait a minute,
what's crazier?
The guy that may like texted dictator is Dick,
or like people like saying that democracy is bad and I'm like,
this is a weird battle.
So,
but that stayed with me and then when I started at quest and we were helping all
these kids are working with all these kids and I saw how extraordinary they
weren't,
which by the way drug dealers,
some of them are amazing entrepreneurs and so it became this notion in my.
It's unreal.
Did I'll tell you some stories sometimes.
Sure.
Absolutely.
Fucking crazy.
And I thought,
Jesus,
you're a better entrepreneur than I am.
Like they're telling me how they watched like the cop cars and when they change
shifts and how they know that they're being identified by their cars.
And so they changed cars all the time as crazy.
And so I'm like,
Jesus,
it gave me this concept that I called mining for astronauts
and I'm like in here,
in here,
somewhere in here being the ghetto are some of the most amazing minds I've ever
come across.
And these guys could be anything.
It can be fucking astronauts,
right?
Like whatever they wanted,
but they don't believe they can.
And when I would interview them it was nuts.
So imagine you're interviewing.
And I came up with just like a fast weighted where I didn't have to think I
could just ask the same questions and one of the questions was a magic genie
shows up is going to grant you one wish and one in which only you can't wish for
more wishes.
You can't cure cancer.
Bringing anybody back from the desk.
I'd be something for yourself.
What do you wish for universally to a person?
They all said a job.
Okay,
that makes sense.
If you think that's what I want to hear.
So you're trying to get a job so you can tell me you want a job.
Then when we get past that bullshit,
and I tell you,
obviously that's not true,
like what do you really want?
Like what's the job to get you money?
Okay.
Do you want money or is it something else?
No,
it's money.
Awesome man.
It's a magic genie can ask for whatever you want.
What do you want?
You know what answer?
Every single one of them gave me.
Well $1,000,000.
You can't buy a fucking house for a million dollars.
K,
it was so crazy.
It's a magic genie.
Joe.
Like you can ask for a trillion dollars,
but their frame of reference was so small.
One guy,
this was like the one exception said he wanted an airport.
I found that so weird.
So I had to push them.
That one I was like,
why an airport?
He said,
because business guys come through the airport and I was like,
okay,
what?
What good does that do you?
And he said,
because then they can teach me about business.
Nothing about that for a second.
How Fun
can many steps removed are you from what you actually want?
But that's like they don't have you say,
I'm a systematic thinker,
right.
So I had to learn that that's not where I started.
So I spent thankfully one of the things I'm most grateful for in my life.
I have to learn everything the hard way,
but because I learned things the hard way,
then I can show other people what I did,
where I fell down and how hopefully they can avoid some of the mistakes.
That's what you need is,
is a
bathroom would adore that faces outside.
The worst is when you go over a girl's house and you go to use her bathroom and
you smell matches.
Oh yeah.
Oh No.
She was like,
this motherfucker up
tall.
You're thinking about burning it off fumes.
Yeah,
just stinky.
But I hate about her.
Matthew ever get to a girl's place and then you feel the gurgles and you're
like,
I could have had that before.
I was dating a girl once.
She had ferocious diarrhea.
Ferocious.
So she was seeing regularly or just one time.
And she.
So she went to the bathroom and she just turned on the shower and she turns on
both things on the sink.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I just tried to drown it out.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
I was very young at the time.
It didn't understand what.
I was super confused.
What the fuck is going on in there?
I had,
I had once in,
in college where I was at this girl's place and she was just like,
Hey,
it's game on,
like go for it.
Right?
It's like I have to take and I could feel that it was a diarrhea,
explosive diarrhea shit.
And I also realized there was no way to do it that,
that it would just a black toilet and there's no way I could cover.
So you know what I did?
I went back to my place.
I was like,
I'll,
I'll see you some other time or whatever.
And the next day her friends were like,
you're like the fucking.
Like they gave me credit that they,
they thought that I was a good kid.
They're like,
you're awesome.
And I was like,
no,
I had to take my girls do that because they're not getting fucked and they don't
want their friend to get fucked.
Right.
So they used reverse psychology on you.
You're an amazing guy.
Got An amazing guy.
Credit.
Help you.
Wait forever is so cool that you left.
Even when you get married.
Tell her we'd get married
to have sex after you're married.
It's not about that.
It's about real love.
Twilight love.
If I had had bowels that were intact,
it would have been a different story that night.
Owls,
bowels,
bowels.
Yeah.
There's a time when you know that it's.
And the sensitivity of your inner asshole region.
It is.
It knows.
Especially when you go to seep out a Fart,
right?
When you like you like about to cut a fart.
And then also the alarms start going off.
Oh No.
Oh yeah.
You got to clamp shot.
You're like,
Jesus,
what is this?
We were having this debate yesterday about why are they sometimes hot,
like why is it hot?
And then why does,
why do you know that hot is going to smell bad spicy food bro?
Is it?
But is that what it is?
Solely imagine?
I don't know.
I,
I'm,
I was telling you guys at one time my freshman year,
I didn't take a ship for a week and a half.
I was addicted this fake,
right?
French fries.
Listen to me.
How long is that?
I was in when I was five.
I played freshman ball and we were playing paterson eastside.
Wait,
just a jungle over school.
Like you gotta be careful when you're going there.
And we went there to play the Christmas tournament.
Well,
what kind of ball are we talking right now?
Basketball and I hadn't taken a shift for like 10 days or something.
I took acid.
Something fucked my stomach up.
I didn't tell nobody.
In those days I was really scared of doctors and I wouldn't say shit to nobody.
Way Home.
We got on the bus
and while we will wait that my stomach started hurting.
I said,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know if I'm going to shit myself a fort,
but let me just take a chance.
Good move,
and I blew this fart Joe Rogan.
That was so bad,
right?
We want a bus,
and people started running.
You know the school buses.
People started running to the windows right to swing down the bus windows,
but he is what you to by the father.
Again,
as the teachers would go,
oh my God,
he's changing flavors.
Yeah,
but
what's the worst thing was the cheerleaders are crying.
That's how bad it was sitting in front of the bus going,
changing teachers yelled,
oh my God,
he's changing.
That's how bad it was.